non jacques myard mer et l'air de
maisons laffitte bonjour et bienvenue
sur rt france d'alors quatrième samedi
de mobilisation à quoi peut-on
s'attendre craignez-vous des
débordements écoutez il est évident que
la question fondamentale des
débordements ce sont ces celle des black
blocks je m'étonne que ce gouvernement
n'a pas encore pris la mesure et les
mesures pour les arrêtées préventivement
vous savez il existe sans sa gamme de
méthodes pour pouvoir les arrêter
je me souviens que notamment au japon et
la police se lance des filets sur ces
individus et donc ils sont pris dans les
filets je dirais la main dans le sac
ce sont des méthodes et puis ensuite il
y à la nécessité du renseignement vous
allez quand même pas me faire croire que
ces blacks blocs ne sont pas déjà
maintenant connus et qu'il faut bien sûr
parce qu on est dans un état de droit
des preuves formelles mais il ya un
moment
lorsqu on pille lorsqu on tabasse
lorsqu'on violente et bien on prend les
moyens de sa politique
or ce gouvernement ne les a pas encore
pris j'espère qu'il va le faire
ce qui est certain c'est qu'il faut bien
voir une chose c'est qu'en réalité ces
manifestations qui sont à répétition et
qui viennent on va le dire
après je dirais un ras-le-bol général à
l'égard du gouvernement
en réalité ce que cela traduit bien sûr
y'a les casseurs mais ce que cela
traduit c'est leur ras-le-bol des
français à l'égard de ce gouvernement
qui n'a plus sa crédibilité quand vous
songez que depuis pratiquement
maintenant deux ans il ya eu la sphère
des gels et jaune ensuite il ya eu les
affaires du terrorisme bien évidemment
il y à toute une multitude de de
violence de manifestations il y a bien
sûr la sécurité globale avec ce fameux
article 24 qui est une bévue monumentale
d'une faute
il est évident que aujourd'hui ce
gouvernement n'a pour le protéger que
les forces de police
or on entend le prêt
dans la république notamment dans un
entretien qu'il a donnée à bruch dit pis
que pendre
je dirais et emploie le mot de violences
policières
il est tombé dans un piège tout
simplement parce que il parle trop et
qu'il doit être économe de son discours
lorsqu'on est un président de la
république on doit dire des choses
certes mais on les dit d'une manière
brève consiste percutante et on n'a pas
un pathos qui durera 30 minutes à chaque
fois alors vous le disait un beaucoup de
manifestations à ces derniers temps les
manifestations actuelles et puis celle
du personnel soignant de l'éducation
nationale mouvement des idées jaune
cette colère sociale qui actuellement en
france comment on y met fin à leur
écoute et je veux dire une chose je
pense que le ce gouvernement ne mettra
pas fin malheureusement cela va durer
alors il faut à sa décharge on connaître
que la pandémie n'est pas une chose
facile
on a affaire à un virus mutant un virus
terrible et on a oublié et on a oublié
que la grippe espagnole ça avait duré
deux ans là nous nous en sortons pas
trop mal mais il n'en demeure pas moins
que l'économie va en prendre un coup
donc la colère sociale va suivre la
colère pandémique et donc il est évident
qu'il va falloir changer de politique
pour relancer la machine économique
malheureusement entre temps ce que je
crains c'est la déprime des pressions
psychologiques des français c'est la
raison pour laquelle ils doivent tenir
ils doivent se dire que bien sûr c'est
dur mais qu'il y a eu dans l'histoire
nationale qu'il y a eu dans l'histoire
nationale des périodes bien pire que
dire n'est ce pas de la guerre de 14-18
de 39-45 où la france ait été occupé
donc on doit faire face on doit se
mobiliser mais il est évident
aujourd'hui on a un président de la
république qui a perdu sa crédibilité
il sait hollande disait comme je dis
souvent et le soleil sur le gâteau il
vient nous parler maintenant de sa
maladie de manière quotidienne ce qui
est quand même véritablement le summum
de la manipulation médiatique c'est le
vaccin médiatique qu'il donne
offre en français ce n'est pas
acceptable donc je crois que
malheureusement on va avoir encore une
période très dure qui va durer on va
avoir des élections
bien évidemment il est possible qu'on
lisait d'ailleurs avant 1 le terme
compte tenu de la crise qui est en train
de s'installer
lorsque notamment pour constater qu'à
l'assemblée nationale cette espèce de
hollow majorité hologramme choisis sur
le nom de mâcon seulement contre toute
surprise
eh bien il est en train de s'effriter
est en train de se diviser
donc il n'est pas impossible que
aujourd'hui on est à la veille d'une
crise de régime
très rapidement un monsieur amiard ces
manifestations actuelles sont là pour
dénoncer la loi sécurité globale
l'exécutif voted et réécrire le texte ou
l'abandonner définitivement et vous ayez
un processus parlementaire et où ne à
que c'est le parlement et notamment le
sénat qui va sans doute le faire la
faute à était d'inscrire cet article 24
en ajout de la loi sur la liberté
d'expression de la liberté de la presse
c'est là la faute et donc que lille est
évident qu'il faut protéger les
policiers
l'article 25 d'ailleurs pourrait être le
jeu devrait le véhicule pour protéger
tous les agents publics qui seraient
livrés en pâture sur les réseaux publics
et les réseaux sociaux
donc il est évident qu'il faut que ce
travail aille vite je pense que le sénat
va le père n'en sache sagesse et ensuite
on va revenir mais ça ne suffira pas car
il faut savoir
et pour bien appréhender le fait que les
policiers qui sont le l'ultime rempart
des institutions aujourd'hui en ont ras
le bol sont véritablement déprimé et on
ne gouverne pas un pays avec la police
ce n'est pas vrai il faut avoir un
projet politique qui aujourd'hui fait
défaut jacques mignard merci à vous
d'avoir été notre invité je rappelle que
vous êtes maire les républicains de
maisons laffitte martial